would it be one thing that you want the
Walking Dead fans to know before tuning
in to fear the walking dead this one's
different it will suck you in the world
is amazing I've actually never seen a
pilot that's literally I look back at
the audience and everybody's at the edge
of their seat with their eyes his wife
you don't need to know anything about
the walking dead to really get into the
show I mean it's like you don't have to
have watched the original it's coming
from very different place a very
different time it's before everything's
happened so yes completely refreshing
and different the greatest thing is it
their step ahead of us they have
information that we don't and I think
that that's really really exciting they
don't know if it's a virus or our
microbe they don't know but it's
spreading it is only it takes place
prior to when the walking dead begins
but it is not a prequel setting up any
characters in the rocking desk hayirli
different set of characters entirely
different location there's no overlap
between the two worlds except that it's
the same rules the same space and it
treats the characters in the same weight
and seriousness that we do on on the
walking dead as well you're far away
from suicide oh the themes are the same
you know the themes of like what happens
in society that will change people and
who they will become sort of the basis
of the shower we work so hard and put
our heart and soul into it and we're
very proud of it and we just hope we we
made them happy